we see the result
of bombing
civilian
people
died
last morning
is we was one district a balloon
where people killed
today in other apartments building
we see we don't know exactly the numbers
uh of uh people we
have not interest to every four
but right now close to 50 people
actually evacuate a lot of a lot of them
injured
[Music]
we give the full support to everyone
how would you describe the spirit of the
ukrainian people and your feeling about
this
the spirit right now everyone is angry i
talk to the people they don't want to
live
in this activity
bring much more
energy to everyone and everyone
understand don't want to live want to
depend defend our city
talk to the people they it's not
disappointing
they really upset what
what russian soldiers do it we see them
but
everyone i talk to the people simple
people instead
to make evacuation to the
to west of ukraine
they ask about their weapons and talk
we're ready to be in serial defense and
defend our houses
how can they defend themselves against
attacks like this which are very random
right now it's uh i i call to everyone
every civilian
please spend the time it is possible in
bunkers
and what about the grounds for possible
war crimes and referring these sort of
attacks to the international criminal
court do you think there is a basis for
war crimes being committed here yes of
course it's it's it's international
criminal case what russians do it with
civilian people in our country
we have a lot of examples in other
cities puja airplane gastoni
almost destroyed
right now we see they
break exactly the same what happens in
uh hurricane maria
right now the same scenario we see in
our hometown
you have european leaders coming here
today to here to show their support but
is that enough what else should be
happening it's never enough
with all the unity of democratic war the
world
unity around ukraine is very important
because we fighting not just our for our
city we're fighting right now not just
for our country we're fighting all
together for our our values our
principles